to help our council decide what to do in
our district we want to hear what you
think the question is simple to use
support shops opening for trading on
Easter Sunday I personally think that
should be older as long as employees
aren't pressured into working by
employees threatening that they are
fired or they have restrictions put on
their job because they are just they
want the day off to celebrate for
whatever to consumes one is the way in
which is to Sunday needs to be honored
as a Christian festival and so to
commercialize that to open trading more
than is necessary you is it's sort of a
downgrading and respect wood workers who
wish to have the holiday or wish to
observe the Christian festival would
they be free to opt out of that will get
the unnecessary pressure so putting all
those two things together I think for
this town it's not going to Edwin much
it appeared what they have to say what
do you think let's talk we can make your
feedback nine on our website Facebook or
at any of our service center Easter
trading is just one topic covered in a
dress and your plants visit vomica debby
dot 0 VT thought into to find out more
and have birthday
you
[Music]